[Applause]
okay welcome welcome to the Columbia
world leaders forum we at Columbia are
very privileged we have the UN in New
York the world leaders come and then
they come to Columbia so we are very
privileged to have many of the world
leaders who come to New York all the
time in real estate they say there are
three principals location location
location
Columbia hazard I'm a Columbia cried
myself and I believe we are the greatest
University in the greatest city in the
world I'm not exaggerating so before I
introduce the speaker and I've had a
delightful conversation with her and got
to know her a few minutes before I'd
like to tell you a little bit about
Mauritius hopefully you're a modern
society and you've done your google but
I'd like to point out a few points it's
a small country that has been highly
successful and the story has not really
been told it's a story you should know
it's a story of a country that has many
accomplishments since 1969 when it
became independent
it was mono agriculture effectively in
sugar it's now a world financial center
it's the second in Africa in human
development 15th in the world on ease of
doing business
those are things to be very proud of
unfortunately we read about Singapore we
should also be reading about Mauritius
because it also has a wealth of
accomplishments that need to be told it
is called the pearl of the Indian Ocean
it's been the gateway to investment in
India and it is slowly but steadily
expanding to also be the Gateway to
Africa
why can't it aspire to that it's very
simple it is focused on education among
other things it has a very good educated
workforce it's going to be improving
still further and this is good
foundation for pivoting to Africa which
will have 1 billion more people by 2050
that means it needs leaders and it has
it my own journey to Mauritius started a
few years ago as a board member of
Mauritian companies I was so impressed I
also created a capstone program so that
we did research on Mauritius last year
admittedly as a financial center in the
wake of the Panama papers which raised a
lot of issues about financial centers
and I will say Mauritius is doing very
well but I'd like to re-emphasize the
key from my point is to people and the
people is well education in this regard
I'd like to introduce now the president
of Mauritius because she exemplifies
these strong qualities president core
grib file far column I'm always bad at
pronunciation I father is ah it's been
one of my weaknesses throughout my whole
life is an academic she was a professor
she was a Dean she was a vice-chancellor
she has focused on what I consider the
most important focus students they are
the next generation they are the future
and as you can see although I deny it
all the time I have something called
gray hair gray hair usually comes when
you get a little bit older although I'm
young what does that mean
it means we have to leave a legacy and
that is what one of her accomplishments
she has focused on people she has also
been an entrepreneur because she's
focused on medicine
African the history of Africa and the
knowledge of Africa on what is
University which it has which can be the
cure for future she has created a
database and also done the
entrepreneurial in fact you can say
she's done it all what do I mean
she's now president of our country so
her life is one of accomplishment and
giving back that is something to be
proud of and she also is very dear to
the heart of Columbia she focused on
biodiversity conservation and
sustainable development we know we like
those topics so without further ado I'd
like to just say one more thing about
the president because I'd like to focus
on the words of her presentation
rethinking Africa's future through
science technology and innovation
science and technology is not sufficient
it's how you innovate it only if you do
something with it do you bring progress
and it's not just on rethinking
Mauritius this future it's thinking
Africa's future it's thinking for the
whole world so it is my great pleasure
to have the president of Mauritius tell
us how Mauritius has done it where it's
going for Africa for Mauritius and then
we will have a question and answer and I
hope you do Columbia proud by asking
insightful questions thank you
[Applause]
Thank You faculty students ladies and
gentlemen good morning it is a pleasure
to be guests here at your world-class
institution it gives me a chance to
reciprocate the recent visit of one of
your own doctor and sing a Columbia law
student who came to Mauritius last
summer for research on his capstone
project Singh did a study on the tax
structure of my country looking at the
road that Mauritius plays in the
economic development of Africa I'm
pleased to report that his findings
again subject to debates professor ah
and endorsements of Mauritius integrity
efficiency in financial standing of the
continents and in the world moreover he
seems to have returned to New York a big
fan of our unique flora our renowned
cuisine and our famously bucolic beaches
they're not necessarily in that order
ladies and gentlemen Mauritius is a tiny
island country of 1.3 million
inhabitants but lies 680 miles of the
east coast of Africa yet
it plays an outsized role in the
economic development of the continent
through a system of bilateral and
multilateral trade agreements across
Africa and the world our commitment to
transparency and cutting red tape as far
as possible
he is reflected in our place as number
one in Africa in the Lagarde important
decks global ranking accounting for the
economy business governor's education
safety and security personal freedoms
social capital and the national
environment these conditions have laid
the groundwork for thriving modern
service sector nourishes and in 2016
economic expansion was driven
predominantly by financial services and
insurance which grew by 5.6 percent last
year and information and communication
technology which grew by 6.3 percent
the success of these sectors plays in
critical role in the economy of
Mauritius and Mauritius plays a critical
role in the economy of Africa their
performance underscores my unequivocal
belief as a scientist and academic but
the separation between the haves and the
have-nots across the globe in the years
to come will be defined by investment in
innovation that's why I'd like to
discuss here with you today as you know
Africa starts at a deficit our home our
continent is home to 15% of global
population but produces only 3% of
global GDP while carrying 25 percent of
global disease burden Africa accounts
for just 2% of world research outputs
1.3 percent of research spending and
0.1% of Haydn's the challenges are
fundamental starting with public
education especially in rural
communities which tend to teach
memorization more than deep in-depth
independent analysis and thinking this
limits the potential students for
creativity and entrepreneurship on a
macro economic level we are persistently
dependent on short-term aid undermining
the obligation of our own government to
create the right conditions to attract
private investment and venture capital
this in turns dilutes our ability to set
our own agenda and take control of and
fully profit from our own economy the
role of government is unique in
addressing major disease pandemics and
preventing future ones only they have
direct access to the magnitude of
funding required and the policy
apparatus necessary to ensure for
example preparedness for pandemic such
as Ebola as well as intervention when
they are upon us
correspondingly African Union nations
have
reached 1% of GDP to research and
development part of the UN's vision for
Africa sustainable development goals
2013 good to see us tickets
this aspirational role validates the
belief that investment in Africa by
Africa herself is essential to long-term
prosperity our particular responsibility
that falls traditional to government is
basic research and targeted fundamental
research on which big advancements often
made pharmaceutical companies whose
mission is to create wealth by
preventing and treating disease cannot
generally justify curiosity-driven
research yet advancements against
disease are often dependent on justice
for example a study revealed that of 10
broadly used clinical advancement for
cardiovascular and pulmonary diseases
such as open heart surgery and drug
treatments of hypertension 42% of the
conceptual steps to the treatment were
from basic research in biochemistry and
the chronology physiology and so forth
similarly recombinant DNA tools
developed from basic structural
discoveries of DNA enable much greater
understanding of bacteria and viruses
nuclear magnetic resonance imaging
dramatically improves Diagnostics all
these advancements were based on
untargeted research resulting from
government investment in basic science
ladies and gentlemen there are certainly
stories success stories in Africa
already the continent is the global
leader in adapting mobile phone
technology for financial services in
2006 according to the Economist there
were fewer than 13 million landlines and
130 million subscriptions to mobile
phones in all of Africa today over a
billion of what 1.2 billion people have
access to mobile phones which serve as a
platform for the delivery of
Kenya is a model for using mobile
technology to provide widespread
services and illustrates it of the
iconic images of Maasai warriors holding
mobile phones in places of speers
over 90% of the people have a mobile
phone the introduction and penetration
of mobile phones set the stage to
develop m-pesa a Kenyan mobile phone
platform 96% of Kenyan households m-pesa
as a vehicle to buy everything from
bananas in the marketplace to school
fees utilities to software for their PCs
it is based on SMS technology not an
application adapted to the limited
resources of a population where 56
percent of those mobile devices are dumb
phones the result of this technology is
that 66% of the Kenyan population is now
banked compared to 20% a decade ago and
exceeding the global average of 62
percent twenty eight billion dollars of
goods and services transited through
empezar
in 2015 equivalent to 44 percent of the
country's GDP
this makes Kenya first in the world not
just on the continent in the penetration
of mobile money transfer technology the
GSMA and international telecommunication
trade body claims that for every 10%
increase in phone penetration poor
countries productivity improves by more
than four percent and that doubling
mobile data usage increases annual
growth in GDP per person by half a
percentage point in Africa is positioned
to continue to lead tech
entrepreneurship as home to the youngest
population of any continent on earth
according to the World Economic Forum in
the ten youngest African countries the
median age is between just 14 to 18 by
2030 for Africa will be home to the
world's largest number of working age
adults the World Bank estimates that
this demographic dividend
could generate 11 to 15 percent GDP
growth over the next 20 years the energy
is palpable with world-class innovation
emerging from technology incubators in
cities from Kigali to Harare to Lagos
venture capital funding of African tech
startups increased by a factor of 10 in
just two years from 41 million dollars
in 2014 to 414 million in 2014 and
projected to reach 600 million by next
year paradoxically one factor that
positioned us to succeed is that in many
industries we have little or no legacy
this relative lack of robust
infrastructure and vested financial
interests means little resistance to the
greater agency for Africa to leapfrog to
better solutions opportunities for
innovation also emerging from
biotechnology and life sciences and this
is the premise of Kerry the Coalition
for African research and innovation
which I serve as chair to the Leadership
Council ladies and gentlemen
Kerry will be an important driver of
African science in the coming years with
seed funding from the Wellcome Trust the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation and
the US and IH it is based on the premise
but world-class pan-african science and
innovation can and will be led by
Africans in Africa with priorities set
by Africa for Africa it is gathering
public and private investment in basic
scientific research and development to
build dramatically scaled up
infrastructure for science it also
advocates for the policy and governance
conditions that enable Africa to claim
her rightful place as a global driver of
prosperity every step in the research
ladder must be reinforced for example
world-class postdoctoral fellowships in
African laboratories are virtually
non-existent forcing our new PhDs who
aspire to research career to train
overseas
many never return professionally which
is their loss and Africa's loss african
research universities must serve as
training debaters to serve up to set up
a virtuous cycle of highly trained
researchers who can in turn provide
guidance and practical training to
graduate students and postdocs our well
being is also critically dependent on
how we manage climate change our
research investment choices it clicks
squarely at the crossroad of
environments and the economy economic
modeling of the impacts of climate
change on Africa predicts a mean average
global temperature rise of 1.5 degree by
2040 with cost equivalent to 1.7 percent
of Africa's GDP
as the mean temperature rises to topo2
degrees by 2060 economic costs increase
to the equivalent of 3.4 percent by the
end of the century with a mean
temperature rise of 4.1 degrees
centigrade the economic costs are
equivalent to just under 10 percent of
the continents GDP we must look beyond
fossil fuels and the extractive
industries to develop renewable
resources to curb climate change and
ensure sustainable economic development
think about the potential of our oceans
as a source of food and in energy and
incubator for biodiversity the oceans
are home to about 2 million species from
the largest animal that has ever lived
to the tiniest bacterium marine
biodiversity far outweighs that inland
oceans cover 71% of our planet's surface
and our life support system for Earth
and provide more than half of the oxygen
we breathe they are central in the
planetary water cycle but produce rain
and snow and nourish more than 1 billion
people with their primary source of
animal protein the oceans also regulate
the global climates mediate temperatures
and drive the weather determining
rainfall droughts and plants they are
the world's
to store of carbon an estimated 83
percent of the global carbon cycle is
circulated through marine waters
Africa's flora and fauna is a similar
source of natural wealth conserving
these resources is critical as by
diversity underpins the food we eat
when this resource is conserved farmers
and scientists can use it to adapt
challengers down the road
I remain engaged with this conversation
with the food forever initiative to
preserve a little biodiversity as the
diversity of crops and livestock are
fundamental to our many challenges this
is especially critical for a small
island country like Mauritius with a
relatively lack of oil and mineral
resources compared to many other African
countries I recently wrote an article
published in Nature twenty score how our
plants and animals can be a source of
big human and financial dividends today
60% of commercially available drugs are
based on molecules derived from natural
resources as an organic chemist and by
diversity scientists I find its
significance but while about 25% of all
plant genetic resources reside in Africa
a just 83 of the 11 plant derived drugs
marketed globally are synthesized for
African species on our continent 45,000
plant species are unexplored for their
potential to serve as the molecular
basis of pharmaceuticals and African
species are disappearing at almost twice
the global rate driven by climate change
habitat loss and development ladies and
gentlemen mauritius by any standard is
tiny and even though mauritius and
nearby islands are designated by buzz
diversity hot spots almost hundred
species have become extinct since the
arrival of man in the 17th century and
only 2% of our forests remain yet with
the right priorities small countries can
punch above their weight a financial
commitment to drug development is
necessary but not sufficient it also
requires the right
technical legal regulatory and cultural
conditions to encourage research
investment to this end I have found the
center the salt that the national
delivery of 46 ADP which searches for
ingredient from our local species for
potential development while African
nations are rich and growing source of
fossil resources home to six of the top
10 global discoveries in oil and gas
sector in 2013 alternative to extractive
industry sources of energy are essential
for sustained African economy an extract
of the hoodia cactus plant long used by
the Sun people to control hunger have
been explored as an appetite suppressant
by Pfizer and Unilever other extracts of
African plants including nuts of the
Shire butter seed oil of baobab are used
commercially in skin and beauty products
our natural world has also inspired
commercial products using biomimicry
such as vertical haulers imitating
inchworms
spiders mimicking robots develop
research and rescue and prosthetic limbs
model encephalopathy tentacles all these
opportunities is leverage perhaps more
critically at the point of development
known as the value of death
the transition from lab bench to
marketplace at this critical juncture
significant resources are necessary to
overcome the research regulatory
economic clinical legal and other
barriers to drug development such as the
dead in containing the Ebola outbreak
before it became a global scourge
addressing these challenges involves
many moving parts our health and
prosperity sit at the Nexus of not just
the interdependent transdisciplinary of
scientific research but in a broader
context of the intersection of nutrition
health agriculture environment
governance and economy it requires
sustained operational funding in capital
supports and their capacity to engage so
especially with funders government
policymakers communities and other
stakeholders only significant investment
in all these elements public private
investment in basic Applied Research
exploiting sustainable resources
creating the legal regulatory and policy
conditions to encourage research and
development the right education and
training for the next generation of
scientists here on the continent will
create a sustainable research and
innovation environment buckley's - less
disease more prosperity and more
independence in Africa a small country
emerges provides prefer principle that
intelligence strategic investment can
yield important returns the challenge is
not easy reaching it depends on
contribution of highly skilled
individuals an ambitious initiative such
as Carrie ladies and gentlemen it can be
done because it must be done our ability
to create a sustained future for
ourselves isn't optional it's
existential there's an African proverb
that says the best time to plant a tree
was 20 years ago the second best time is
now so bring your seedlings and shovels
and we'll plant the tree together thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
now you can see why I fell in love with
Mauritius when I went lots of food for
thought thinking and it's clear that
small countries like Mauritius really
punch above their weight they have
things to say we have things to learn
thank you we are now open for questions
Columbia is known for good questions so
there's a mic on each side if you would
stand up get on line and when you I call
upon you for the questions please give
you a name your Columbia affiliation and
obviously the question is not to me but
to her while you are lining up I will
ask a minor question to just get the
ball rolling you've given a perspective
very good one of where Africa is the
potential and how it needs to be part of
the world and needs to do more research
but can you give us just a microcosm of
where will Mauritius be within that
sphere let's say 25 years for now if not
50 years now what's your vision thank
you for that reflection in fact this is
the question that gets asked to
countries which are progressing which
are doing perceived to being quite well
but the same time it's a reflection that
makes us think where we want to be is
the benchmark going to be only per
capita income or is the benchmark going
to be creating a portion tiers for our
young people of course this will lead
eventually to the per capita income but
I think what we have to do is to look at
our strengths the weaknesses perform the
usual swap and see what the strengths
are for Mauritius I can safely say right
now standing that this reflection should
have been done yesterday so that we can
better position ourselves but I think
our strength would be in initially three
sectors the green the blue and the white
economies the white I would say is the
services I think we're doing quite well
there but to create opportunities
we need to develop this innovation space
we need to develop the songs technology
space and this can be done through where
we're strong we are by diversity
hotspots so we have plenty of green
material to work through to generate
these innovative as you know steps so
that we create jobs also for our youth
but one thing also must be very very
mindful of is that Africa is the young
continent I've mentioned it already so
we will be able we need to create jobs
we need to create a niche a continent
about open air and this can only be done
when we start a reflection process now
or yesterday but having said this and
this were shared with Professor just
before coming here our responsibility is
to create strong prosperous institutions
and we are here today Colombia has a
fantastic reputation because this
Guardian the the the founding fathers of
this institution they have appointed
Guardians they have appointed guardian
to preserve the reputation of this place
and when we leave this place it is our
responsibility to leave it a stronger
institution than when we found it thank
you we'll start on with you
Thank You president for coming and
speaking today I'm Sarah by
undergraduate senior in the college here
sitting English literature and ecology
evolution elemental biology I was very
impressed by your dedication to research
especially giving funding especially
critical funding to research and
biodiversity research as well and I was
wondering you know next few decades as
the growth of Mauritius continues what
do you see for the role of artists and
scientists working together how will say
artists and writers also you know work
alongside scientists bring a country
like Mauritius - it's really forefront
and what do you see as potentials and a
small side note what is your favorite
Mauritius artist or writer um thank you
I just I just read recently that
somebody like Charles Darwin and even
great scientists like Newton in some of
the favorite past-time they were reading
perch
so you can be driven by science but I
think what we have to do is use culture
also as a source of innovation and
recently I hosted the conference of the
Statehouse where I brought people from
the walks of Arts Nature and Science and
brought them together and it was
impressive to see the innovative
thinking but you can get I think a
culture and art would actually be part
of this whole dynamics that if we want
to ensure creativity and lateral
thinking critical thinking it comes to
an artist viewpoint it comes from a
scientist but together we can make it
even bigger
and I think this is a space where I find
that the famous edition of one point one
one plus one gives three and my artist
Morrison artists are quite a few but I
think I would stay with step I will not
mention those who are living it may
create some but in the past we had great
people like Rizal and so these are they
remain in your big names in in my
country thank you thank you for your
remarks my name is Mark I'm studying
international affairs at SEPA focusing
on political development previously I
worked in Tanzania and East Africa and
economic development and there I saw
that issues with poor governance and
corruption could be restricted to the
type of sustainable growth you've talked
about so I'm curious from a leaders
perspective how technology and
innovation can boost good governance and
and battle some of the restrictive
forces such as stagnancy and corruption
restricting some of Africa's economies I
think you the answer isn't your question
because with technology with the
adoption of technology at many in many
many governments in many government
departments we should be able to tackle
not only the red tape but also the
corruption and this is again something
where Mauritius is also moving towards
for example if you look at the revenue
Authority it is essentially digitized
and we also using the same approach for
acquiring permit because this is where
again there can be tendency for
corruption so using technology for the
betterment of the functioning of
institution there's no doubt that
technology has a very big place to play
and you have you have another party
question that's fine just wanted to say
thank you thank you thank you for your
speech as a fellow Mauritian it's a
pleasure to see you at the worlds farm
my name is dawn kasanete and I'm a
sophomore Tonga college so my question
concerns brain drain and as you know
it's a significant issue for the country
so I'm curious about your views on the
issue and what in your opinion is the
biggest incentive for students like me
we're studying abroad to come back to
the country afterwards mm-hmm thank you
I asked the same question almost 30
years ago
when I finished my studies they were
debate was whether I should come to the
u.s. in fact I was offered a postdoc
here or to go back I went back and like
Edith Piaf says general criteria but I
think you know now we are in a dynamic
where we cannot say we should have to
operate for Brain Gain I am much more of
the opinion that we have to operate in
the scenario of brain circulation
because a Mauritian doesn't have to be
in Mauritius to contribute to Mauritius
they can be elsewhere and now with the
power of technology we can leverage all
this talent that aspera
offers internationally into what we can
do emerges and but I think also if we
want to go towards this Brain Gain the
way most people would like to see it I
think it's the responsibility of leaders
in the country not just in Mauritius in
Africa to create an ecosystem which is
far better than what you are getting
here I mean it may seem like you know
lofty idea that I'm actually coming up
with but this has been the scenario in
China this has been the scenario in
India this having the scenario in many
emerging countries that they say okay if
you want to attract these talents back
we have to give them the space we have
to give in the echo system we have to
give them the opportunities for them to
flourish and this is one was the reason
why I push me to chair Kerry because for
Kerry we're trying to do just this build
the ecosystem in their respective
countries where the challenges are where
the problems are so
that we can get these talents to come
back at least if not permanently because
nothing is permanent but this from that
particularly much in time they will come
they will be able to share the expertise
and talents so the onus is on both of us
so you are lost by not coming to
Mauritius and our loss for not having
you there thank you professor and
president I'm really excited to listen
to your remarks today I'm currently an
undergraduate freshman at Columbia
University study biochemistry I'm
recently really interested about the
research in Mauritius I call two
questions the first is how is Mauritius
balancing the fundamental basic science
research which may have potentially the
future and technology driven industry
leaders research which may have
potential today and second question is
about the trust
medicine translational medicine process
in Mauritius you mentioned that
Mauritius is encouraging scientists and
entrepreneurs during Ebola research and
some kinds of cancer so how is Mauritius
encouraging the trance medicine process
that to convert the research in the
laboratory to a clinical application in
market thank you like I just mentioned
in the speech that if you look at the
corporates a big pharma company it is
not in the business plan to encourage
curiosity-driven research which is of
course the the basics on which you know
a lot of spin-offs are obtained further
down the line so this is a
responsibility for governments to
actually invest in that space it's it's
a challenge because when there is not
that vision that that blueprint as to
where we want to go in 25 years time in
50 years time this is a question
answered Arirang it is difficult to know
where we're going because we will not
get the proper commitments so you need
to have a plan you can tweak it along
the line but please you know that this
is the commitment that has to be brought
in so that the research is sustained
in the long term because fundamental
research will not happen on the
short-term it's a long-term investment
we have digital cameras nowadays this
because the observation that Einstein
made nineteen fifties so it's a very
long-term investment the blue sky
research demands a lot of investment but
we recognize that some countries can't
do it for many reasons you know not
enough GDP per capita you name it all
the challenges there and this is where
we have to rope in and engage with
philanthropist and it has happened in
the u.s. we've seen for example projects
I mean you have got the the Facebook the
Google they are all emanation of some
degree of philanthropy and this is a
dialogue we are engaging with African
philanthropists we engage also in
dialogue with governments that they need
to have this blueprint they need to have
this investment so that they sustain
this research capacity the second point
you mentioned is a translation Mauritius
is offers offers a very interesting case
study if I may say so my mantra since I
become president I have said that our
diversity is our strength it's not
social it is not cultural although it is
that as well but it is also we are we
are home to the four genetic types
emerges so we have all the four races
living there and this was one of the
premises on which I picked my company
because we had the biodiversity which
are of course unique but we also have
the people now how do you make it work
is that recently in New York Times there
was an article that a lot of products
from the pharma industry fail because
they have not been tested sufficiently
on diverse populations and this is
something that we have we capitalized
upon so if Mauritius wants to go that
extra mile in development we really need
to rethink our strengths and our
diversity is our strength but more
importantly we can also be beacon of
peace because our social fabric has been
shown to be highly resilience in spite
of our of our differences so learn from
our differences exchange and enrich
ourselves and not let it be a divisive
force
hi my name is Roberta Bev I'm from
Lebanon
I'm studying urban and social policies
master degree thank you for your
inspiring speech really and no Sophia vu
we as women we're very proud of you my
question is that you mentioned in your
speech that the top priority of the
government at the macro level was
transparency and governance and you know
as you know the World Bank and IMF also
appraised Mauritius you know record
regarding this point what would the main
challenges for the government to shift
the mind of the investors foreign
investors even local investors on the
importance of transparency and
governance you've also mentioned that's
on another note if I might aloud
professor you've men should also
capstone last year I'm part of a team
working on a capstone on India foreign
investment in India so what's your
personal opinion the main challenge for
India to attract foreign investment with
regard to governance and transparency um
thank you you know if we want to attract
if I want
I'm investor you're investor you won't
invest in country X we want to ensure
that your capital is there in its
preserved and you want to have in a
facilitation process that will make sure
that you get in return on investment and
it is critical that there are these
countries country X while you're going
to invest has the rule of law so
assuming that tomorrow you're not happy
there you can repatriate your money it's
it's it's a work in progress in most
countries but having said this I will be
cliche here for every corrupt T there is
a Corrupter so we don't need to look at
the behalf to look at ourselves how are
we doing things right are we adhering to
all these values but we have been
calculated
families will tell you to do things
right to do things properly because a
corrupt action a corrupt practice these
attacks on the poor and this is
something that we have to be very
mindful of so in every country in every
institution let's just try to go back to
this very boring values but they are
fundamental values that we have to
adhere to and the next thing you
mentioned is about capital investments
in India we have been a gateway for a
lot of investments in India and India
has changed the law recently mindful of
all the or all the dynamics which are
going on but I think one thing also we
have to be very very careful and know
that we are living in the digital age we
are living in a time where information
is available we are living in time where
information is instantaneous so it is
our duty it is our responsibility to
make sure that we preserve as far as
possible the jurisdiction and it's down
to each individual to do things properly
I hope I've answered your question thank
you and I had a question about
continuing and foreign investment in
Mauritius and wishes is an incredible
job with investment has continuously
been in the top twenty two word invest
in Africa but it hasn't yet broken on
the top ten weird in resin Africa often
depend on the size of the domestic
market so in a question of how to kind
of continue to bring in a foreign
investment and then also kind of
balancing foreign investment with kind
of working on the populist and kind of
bringing an internal investment as well
what we have been doing over the past
five six years is to increase a lot of
lateral and multilateral exchanges with
many regions in Africa and but of course
the all this is working progress so we
have to really really get our
jurisdiction to see to it that it
matches the international norms and all
this is work in progress but having said
this you know the investment is
happening but you know we have to keep
on modifying and ensuring that we do
business perhaps differently
and maybe if we engage more with African
continent we will see a lot more intra
Africa trade for example because if you
look at the European Union
it's in excess of 45 percent and in
Africa is nothing less than 20 percent
so there is a huge potential market
within the African country itself but
our job now is to see to it that's all
the regulations all the you know the
document that we have standard eta at
the double taxation die PPA and all
these they are attuned with what's going
on and all this is working progress
hello my name is Makar Sonali I'm a
freshman in the Columbia College thank
you for your speech it was very
enlightening my question like several
the before me has to do with corruption
so the Economist ranks Marisha is very
highly probably in terms of having a
true democracy my question is what
factors allow Mauritius to be marked as
having a true democracy and what can
other African nations that deal with
long lasting issues from imperialism
natural disasters and lack of diverse
economies do to see anti-corruption such
as in Nigeria with Buhari or Tanzania
with Marga Fuli what can they do to see
anti-corruption as a norm as opposed to
a trend Mauritius is a country that
became independent 1968 a living
apologies for having a colonial past we
all had it in Africa but I think what we
the most important decision we took over
and above I think the Stiglitz wrote
about this the Mauritius story of having
all the social protection health care
but after the most important one amongst
the others is free education free
education as we all know it's a social
enabler it's a vehicle when people are
highly educated you can actually you
know put messages across faster better
and this is again something that we we
are doing and we also give a lot of
facilities to to people who want to do
continuous learning and I think through
this vehicle we should be able to it to
do you know many changes including
addressing corruption or as I said which
is a attacks on the poor and it is
something we have to tackle up front and
it's not acceptable you mentioned our
good number
the numbers in terms of the ranking but
you know all this it depends whether the
glass is half-full or half-empty and
what you want to benchmark yourselves so
maybe we should benchmark ourselves more
perhaps through the nordic countries
which are doing even better so all this
is work in progress hi my name is
Leonard sim Akula I am a freshman at
Columbia College I'd like to thank you
for your words today we really thought
provoking and me coming from Uganda in
African country I really hold the ideas
you expressed really but what I would
like to know today is your opinion on
all of the international aid flowing
into the continent and whether it has a
place in a developing Africa and whether
it in fact leads to sustainable
development well you can be cliche you
can say but people have been saying more
trade and less aid this has been the
mantra in many many agendas I think the
aid has been useful if you look at for
example the intervention in West Africa
recently with Ebola crisis it has helped
bring the country that the region back
again to the fold but I think it's it's
also up to us nations African nations to
really take our destiny in our hands and
we have to invest in our own people we
have to create the space
I think donors money is very good seed
money but we have to make sure that
whatever achievements have been made
with the help of doing and money is
sustained with our own contribution so
if we want for example to educate our
people we have to put money I don't have
to put our hands now pop it it is not
going to be made possible by aid money
only so we have to speak to ourselves
and we have to ensure that we invest in
our people and I said again that
stressed the point we have to invest in
our people in our institutions and this
our responsibility to see to it that
young people like yourself you asked for
more accountability from your
governments
good morning madam president
I'm a visiting scholar from Shanghai
China and thank you very much for your
elegant excellent speech I'm very glad
to learn such great progress in your
country in science technology and
innovation I have two questions one has
two years compared to the amount of
another island country dependent much
trollese economy I want to know what
what kind of advantage that your country
have and the second question years in
this June so the Arabic and the other
and with some other Arabic country cut
their ties with the Qatar and I want to
know what sort of opinion on these Garf
quizzes thank you the I the country
mentioning about of Molina yeah okay
sorry can you repeat the question the
more lives again compared to the more -
another island country dependent much
dependent much our tour is an economic
what kind of advantage do your country
have just like Maldives tourism is one
pillar on the economy of Mauritius but
you'd be surprised to be able to tell
you that tourism accounts for less than
ten points on the economy of a country
more is coming now from the services the
service sector and all that so tourism
it's the product that needs to be
innovated all along what do we do when
we actually offer a tourism package we
sell dreams we do that we do it we know
we create an image around this but
having said this when the tourists
reaches our shores it is our duty to
ensure that the torus is safe the
tourist is getting value for money and
of course we deliver on the promises
we've made
and Maldives is the country will I can't
comment technically on another country
but just for comparison sake it's the
country which depends a lot on tourism
but now with climate change maybe there
would be a rethinking process to be to
happen very very fast because all these
regions with the acidification of the
ocean with the rise of sea level so this
is going to pose a problem to the region
and of course to Mauritius as well will
also be impacted and we already
witnessing for example most severe
storms we just seen - in the Caribbean
recently but week nobody is spared
nobody's better on these catechist
active natural activities so tourism is
one but we have to keep on diversifying
the economy so that you know when the
disaster strikes we you know the economy
is not flat outs so and second one is
about the ties with Qatar we have
demotic links with with the country our
our foreign policy is that we are
friends to all and enemies to none so
that's it thank you hi my name is Zohar
karmani and I'm a student grad student a
master student of sustainability
management I had a question on
are you satisfied by the ways by which
companies in mauritius contribute
towards sustainable development through
their sustainability in csr programs and
if not what would you like to see them
for do further thank you I think already
the fact that they contribute to the
corporate social responsibility I think
about 2% of the the gross again it's the
income but unfortunately it's the net
income that the gross income but I see
the fact that they contribute is already
is already something and government has
been trying to put guidelines to ensure
that you know those who are most
deserving they actually benefit from
this CSR but of course like anything
else you know is
is its official is the glass half full
or half empty but I think you know we
can still do much more but you have to
make sure that those who are more
deserving they are you know we target
them more so that you know their
livelihoods get improved and we come out
a much stronger society because we would
have reduced the gap in the haves and
have-nots thank you
we unfortunately can only take one more
question so you will be the last so make
it good okay that's a lot of pressure hi
my name is shreya
I'm software NCC studying economics
first of all thank you for your speech
Madam President my question was you
talked about the takeoff of impossible
banking in Kenya and my question is sort
of threefold I was wondering what you
felt it was about like the regulatory
environment and in general the economic
environment in Kenya that allowed mobile
banking to take off do you feel that
such a trend is kind of on the way are
already happening in Mauritius and if
not where do you sort of see is the
future of technology and specifically
financial technology in Mauritius well I
think an peso has been revolutionary in
as much as it has made so many people
who'd never had bank account they
actually had they can do the transaction
straight on unwell phone now you can
also ask the question about the
intellectual property of m-pesa whether
it's really benefiting Kenya that's
another story I'm not going to delve
into this but you can go and check it
out but so we have the equivalent of
these platforms in Mauritius now where
we can do transfers financial transfer
but the government is very keen on
financial technologies and we've had a
workshop this year and we're looking at
our laws in a regulatory environment to
make it happen because we realize that
so much can be done and so much can be
gained through this through this
technology so again if that sort of
interest to you then I can connect you
to the relevant authorities who can have
much more to tell you in terms of these
new technologies new approaches thank
you
before I thank the president for her
inspirational remarks I'd like to note a
number that she has made she's made many
but
think they're food for thought culture
as a source of inspiration that says a
lot
brain circulation I like that we're all
one we don't we can go away but we're
still part of the whole curiosity and
research versus the big farmer yes we
need the government one that I hope the
message goes to Washington DC our
diversity is our strength so is ours we
can learn from our differences so I
don't know if you wanted a political
message but you gave one free education
yes is the sauce
education is the groundwork what we do
with it is another but without it we do
not have anything don't know money yes
is only seed money
it's the beginning it's not the end and
invest in people you have to it's the
same as that one educate so she's given
a lot of food for thought it's
inspirational Columbia students have
done well by asking good questions so
thank you for being here thank you for
being with us and come back please
[Applause]